Growing up I always wondered what my super power would be,
would it be telepathy?
- (cat's mind) Fish
Fish Dude you already ate. - (cat's mind) Fish? - Hungress I don't have any
(cat's mind) Fish!
(cat's mind) fish...
(cat's mind) fish, fish, fish.
Telepathy when you're a cat owner sucks - (cat's mind) fish - would it be time travelling?
Todays video is sponsored by ChromeBook.
Awww I've made so many branded babies with ChromeBook, what video is this?
How to get stuff done. [sigh] Our first collab.
The next one is about being prolific it's pretty dope.
Thanks girl! Are you from the future you look really good? Technically...
I'm the present and you're the past but thanks! I'm 40 now.
Wait what. Perhaps telekinesis.
Move.
Like... Like here?
Little to the left.
Here? - Little to the right.
Just... Just tell me when.
Keep going.
Anytime soon?
Ehh never mind just put it back where it was. But instead I got the greatest...
superpower of them all, prolificness.
Which I think is uh much more useful that telepathy cause  [chuckles]
I don't wanna know what goes on in anyones head, no thank you. First thing...
is having a clear vision. The new year is coming up...
which is the perfect time to outline your goals.
I love goal setting! You wanna think big picture.
My favourite way of doing this is either by a vision board or a...
bubble map, because it's a constant visual reminder of...
what you're trying to achieve long-term. And if you're like me...
and you get kinda in the motions of everyday tasks or...
you get really easily distracted and somehow lose hours and hours of your time.
It is very helpful to see a representation of your end product...
on a day to day basis. And with ChromeBook's ability to be a...
Laptop, tablet and tent, you can be productive, creative...
and restful, all without leaving the couch. For up to 10...
hours cause of that super sweet battery. Next...
commit to doing just a little bit each day. When you think of...
progress, imagine a bunch of cups in-front of you. Everyday...
you wanna do what you can to push each of these cups just...
a little bit forward. Somedays you'll push one a tremendous...
amount and that's awesome. But you never wanna get caught up with where that...
cup is and forget all about your other cups. So for me, this means...
scheduling even just 10 minutes a day to work on something...
is better than not working on it at all. Whether you put...
that in your Google Cal or keep a daily habit tracker, do not...
underestimate the power of a little bit every...
day. And if some of your goals involve other collaborators, I...
highly recommend streamlining the process, by creating a...
executable actions list for both of you. I am...
an avid user of Google Docs, not just because of it's sharing...
capability for people that I work with but if I am in...
someplace with no wi-fi, I can still edit offline and re...
sync when I connect to cat kingdom. And the final secret...
to being prolific is being persistent.
Give your goals permission to take time cause when you're in it...
for the long haul, your mindset is more geared towards fun.
You're less likely to be burnt-out if you just tackle little...
pieces each day. And you'll be inspired by your vision...
of the future. I wanna say thank you again to ChromeBook for sponsoring...
todays video. The ChromeBook is sleek and lightweight...
it starts up in seconds and is fast, and my dad is...
constantly harassing me to give him mine. If you would like to learn more about
ChromeBook you can click on the link in the description below. I'm Anna Akana...
and Hungress is purring.